Let's do a little quiz here.
What is true for any valid--and by valid I mean with respect to independent set--
any valid 0, 1 assignment to the vertices v and u if they are connected by an edge?
Is it that at most, 1 of the 2 vertices can be in the independent set--
and I'm going to write independent set as IS here just to not move out of the screen here.
Is it that both v and u can be in the independent set?
Is it that at least 1 of the 2 vertices must be in the independent set
because we're looking for the largest possible independent set?
Could it be that although we're looking for the largest possible independent set,
they are both not contained in that independent set?
And finally here, because both vertices are connected by an edge,
is it the case that we would have to exclude both of these vertices
from the independent set?
Please check each one of those here that are correct.